[موسيقى]
في كتابه بعنوان ساخون وطني يقول الكاتب
العلماني محمد الماغوط من الغباء ان ادافع
عن وطن لا املك فيه بيتا وان اضحي بنفسي
ليعيش اطفال من بعد مشردين ومن الغباء ان
تذكر لامي بفقد وهي لا تعلم لماذا مت ومن
اترك زوجتي فريسه للكلاب من بعدي فالوطن
هو حيث تتوفر لي مقومات الحياه لا مسببات
الموت ويختم المغوط الانتماء كذبه اخترعها
الساسه حتى نموت من اجلهم في مقابل هذه
الثقافه الاشتراطيه والمصرفيه على الوطن
توجد ثقافه اخرى قرات الايه القرانيه
الكريمه
ولنبلونكم بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص من
الاموال والانفس والثمرات
الصابرين صدق الله العظيم قراتها وفهمتها
وعدا للصابرين وبان من يموتون من اجل حياه
الوطن والامه احياء عند ربهم يرزقون ومن
كان الضمانته عند الله لا يريد ضمانه او
تعويضا من احد لكن السؤال العقيم عن
الجواب هو لماذا تاريخيا ومنذ قديم الزمان
تمتلئ سجون الاوطان بالمستعدين للموت من
اجل ان تحيا الاوطان فيما يتبوا صيارفه
المبادئ ولصوص الاحلام ارفع المناصب في
البلاد
الى العناوين
اعلام روسيا في ساحه مسجد بالنيجر ووفاه
مداح بوتين في دمشق
باربيل لعبه الزهريه صارت فيلما مثيرا
للجدل وممنوعا في الكويت ولبنان
اكثر من مليار دولار تسعيره حريه السجين
الامريكي في ايران
انتقاقات في نادي الوحدات الاردني بعد
قرار اللعب مع فريق اماراتي مطبع
اسرائيل تقتل شابا وفتى فلسطينيين
واعلامها يتباهى برقص اسرائيلي اماراتي
قديم
نائب تركي اسمه عربي يعترض على تحيه
السلام عليكم فهل يغير اسمه
طفل يجهس بالبكاء عندما علم لاول مره
بوفاه النبي محمد عليه السلام
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في مثل هذه الايام قبل 10 سنوات لم
يعد مصطلح رابعه عند العرب يقتصر على
تسميه لفتاه او على دلاله عدديه بل صار
هويه وجع شجي على دماء مصرية اهدرت على
ارض مصريه فقتل المئات بالقدر وسكت عنهم
القضاء المصري تقول بي بي سي قبل عشر
سنوات اصر الالاف من انصار الرئيس المصري
المنتخب محمد مرسي على بقائهم في ميداني
رابعه والنهضه في القاهره اعتصاما ورفضا
لدعوات عزله عن الرئاسه في المقابل اصر
الجيش المصري على فض الاعتصام ولو بعمليه
عسكريه من اجل استعاده الامن في البلاد
وفق تبريره لها فنتج عن هذه العمليه
العسكريه
مقتل مئات المعتصمين المدنيين الذين اكلت
الحرائق جثث بعضهم ما حدا بمنظمته
الى وصفها بانها عمليه قتل جماعي ربما تصل
لمصافي الجرائم ضد الانسانيه لم تطو صفحه
رابع العدويه بعد على ما يبدو
القاهره ظاهرها هادئ لكن جنباتها تحمل
حزنا وغضبا
لم يحاسب احد من رجال الدوله فالملاحقات
والمحاكمات كانت من نصيب المعتصمين فحسب
ليضل الشرخ عميقا بين مصريين ومصريين
بعدتهم السياسه وفرقتهم الدماء انتهى عصر
الشيكات النفطي المسيس عنوان مقال سخيف
جديد للصحفي عماد الدين اديب بحسب توصيف
اعلاميين مصريين شبه رسميين اديب نعى
المساعدات الخليجيه المجانيه لمصر وتحدث
وكانه وزير للماليه والدفاع والخارجيه في
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي مجتمعه فاعلن عن
تغييب المساعدات الخليجيه عن اليمن ولبنان
لاسباب امنيه وسياسيه النهارده انا شفت
بلا داعي من ناحيه
السياق بتاع المقال نفسه مش مفهوم منه اي
حاجه غير تقديم مصر وكانها
طل لازمته ايه موقع مجهول الهويه يقول
الصحفي المصري انه لا يعرف موقع اساس
ميديا لكنه لبناني ومعروف في بيروت
والموقع تابع للوزير السابق انه هذا
المسنوق تقديرا لدوره في تنميه العلاقات
الثنائيه بين لبنان ودوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده كرم السفير الاماراتي في
لبنان حمد سعيد الشامسي وزير الداخليه
نهاد المشنوق يمكن برضه دول الخليج استمعت
الى الرئيس الجاليه المصريه في فرنسا صالح
فرهود فاطمئنت الى اوضاع مصر الماليه بعد
اعلان فرهود عن ان مصر جنه اقتصاديه
واوروبا التي يعيش ويتاجر فيها هي الجحيم
متغاضيا عن حلول مصر في المرتبه السادسه
عالميا من حيث ارتفاع اسعار الغذاء احنا
في مصر بخير
الناس اللي قاعده في مصر
ومفكرين ان اوروبا جنه والله ما هي جنه
مصر هي اللي جنه مصر هي اللي فيها شعب
عظيم انا راجل تاجر في في فرنسا
تصور كيلو الطماطم كنا بنشتريه بخمسه اورو
بسته اورو يعني بكم مصري 240 جنيه مصري
وبنقول مصر غاليه فرهود غارق في اسعار
الطماطم واحمد موسى في سعر البصلايه ويطرح
معادله البصل مقابل الدولار فاي عز بلغه
البصل المصري ليباع بالعمله الصعبه
معقول معقوله طبعا
قبل كده لو كنائين البصل
ولا انتم ولا لاقيين اي حاجه
كناش لاقيين صدرنا 300 الف طن السنه دي ده
عائد على البلد على الموازنه وعائد على
اهلنا المزارعين حد بياكل البصل كل يوم
بصلايه
بطبخ بعمل شويه مش عارف ايه محتاج بصل بحط
في الكيلو بصل هي واحده
حد بيستخدم اكتر بصلايه يعني تنفي الحكومه
المصريه اتهامات وجهت اليها بان تكون قد
بدات ببيع الاوقاف الاسلاميه لا سيما بعد
حاله الشك التي اشعلها في الشارع المصري
حريق مبنى وزاره الاوقاف الذي عمل الرجال
الاطفاء على رش شجره مجاوره للمبنى بالماء
وسقياها بدل اطفاء الحريق في الطوابق
العليا
احات شاسعه من
الاراف من الاصول والعقارات بما فيها من
قصور تاريخيه واثريه فضلا عن الاموال ثروه
ضخمه اوقفها اصحابها للعمل الخيري وتديرها
الحكومه المصريه اثير حولها الجدل خلال
الاونه الاخيره بعد شائعات ببيع الدوله
لبعض هذه الاصول لفت الحكومه المصريه ما
يثار حول بيع ممتلكات للاوقاف تقدر قيمتها
بمليارات الدولارات او تلف حجج واسانيد
ملكيتها لاصحابها في الحريق الذي نشب قبل
ايام بمبنى الوزاره
[موسيقى]
احتفى اعلامه موسكو برفع بعض المصلين
المسلمين في النيجر اعلام روسيا نكايه
بفرنسا والغرب عموما اثناء تجمعهم للصلاه
والدعاء باحلال الامن والسلام في بلادهم
وسط تهديدات فرنسيه بشن حرب عسكريه على
قاده الانقلاب على الرئيس محمد بازون
[موسيقى]
القران
الحاله النيجيريه التعاطفيه مع روسيا ليست
الاولى في العالم الاسلامي فان مامون رحمه
الخطيب السابقه للمسجد الاموي في دمشق
لطالما دعا منبر رسول الله محمد عليه
الصلاه والسلام للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين القائد الفد والمحبوب على وصفه كما
وعده بالزحف والموت دفاعا عن تراب روسيا
للقائد الفذ بوتين ايها القائد العملاق
ايها القائد المحبوب فقدت سوريا وروسيا
هذا الاسبوع مامون رحمه حيث توفي عما
يناهز ستين عاما فلا احد في هذا العالم
يستطيع ان يعيش الف عام اذا عشت الف عام
عامل تونس يدعو الى رفع الاستبداد بمن
فيهم الرئيس قيس سعيد فمن هو المستبد يلزم
الشعب التونسي يقف الكل في وجه الظلم وفي
وجه الاستبداد المقنع
بسمه الاستبداد قاعدين يقوموا به الناس
اللي وراء الستار وتحبت اجشج الاوضاع مره
السكر مره دواء مره قهوه
الخبز متوفر ولكن للاسف يحبوا الاوضاع
[موسيقى]
باربي اللعبه زهريه الملابس تحولت الى
فيلم ضد مفهوم العائله وضد اخلاقيات
المجتمع والاديان هذا ما يقوله منتقد
الفيلم الذي منع في الكويت ولبنان بشكل
علني وربما يكون قد حجب بصمت في غيرهما من
الدول العربيه حياه مزيفه عالم بلون واحد
معايير كاذبه للجمال تسريع للمراه ترويج
للنسويه والشذوذ ضرب لمفهوم العائله ابطال
متحولون جنسيا الفاظ نابيه هذا هو مضمون
فيلم باربي اللعبه التي كانت حلمه كل طفله
من واحد اوه زي ما بتتوقع
والشباب باربي لاند ما الهم اي داعي مش
مهمين وبورجوك انه هذا العالم المثالي
العالم اللي بتقدر تعيش فيه بكل راحه انه
ينفصل الرجال عن النسوان بعض النواب
والكتاب في لبنان هاجموا قراره وزير
الثقافه محمد وسام المرتضى قائلين ان منع
الفيلم يجب ان يكون اخر اهتمامات حكومه
لبنان المنكوب لكن الرد جاء بسؤال لماذا
يكون الدفاع اذا عن الفيلم الزهري اول
اهتمامات المعارضه
في المضاربين نجاح عالمي تقابله حاله من
الجدل في صلاه السينما العربيه ففي الكويت
اعلن عن حظر فيلم باربي بوصفه مخالفا
للعادات والتقاليد لتاتي من بعضها لبنان
بذات القرار باحكام تدور حول افكار الفيلم
البشعه على حد وصف وزير الثقافه اللبنانيه
السعوديه سمحت بعرض الفيلم في صلاتها
السينمائيه بدءا من الامس وسط توقعات
باقبال كبير على شباك التذاكر الامارات هي
الاخرى اعلنت الموافقه على عرض فيلم باربي
بعد استكمال اجراءات المتابعه بما يتوافق
مع معايير المحتوى الاعلامي في الدوله هل
ان الحمله على فيلم باربي ساهمت في
الترويج له ربما لكن ما هي الطريقه
للتحذير من شيء دون ذكره بالشيفره السريه
في البحرين باربي صارت شاورما على السيخ
واغلب الزبائن من البنات 90% استمر كله
باربي باربي باربي
انها
[موسيقى]
لقيت الناس كلها هتشد عليها اعجابات باربي
باربي باربي فقلنا لازم نعمل صوص باربي
والله
البنات اكتر عشان يصوروا لازم حتى
الاستيكر الوردي يتحط عليه شاورما باربي
ترند البحرين ولو هل المجتمع وغيره محصن
ليهدده فيلم
والله الغرب حجب نشره الاخبار الروسيه
لانه اعتبرها مهدده لمجتمعه مع انها ماده
جافه بالمقارنه مع السينما الجذابه
هل يمكن ان تؤثر مشاهده فيلم لساعه ونصف
على مفاهيم اجتماعيه وعلى تنشئه الجيل
الجديد نعم تجيب الناشطه الاجنبيه الحسناء
الخاليه من العقد
[موسيقى]
ببساطه قطريه ايران ستفرج عن خمسه
امريكيين مقابل افراز امريكا عن خمسه
سجناء ايرانيين وعن اموال ايرانيه قدرت
على الاقل بسته مليارات وعلى الاكثر بعشره
مليارات دولار يعني
مكلف راس ايراني وفوقه اثنين مليار دولار
او مليار روسوي علما ان واشنطن تدفع
لطهران من جيب طهران خطوه نادره صفقه
ايرانيه امريكيه لتبادل السجناء تتم بعد
عامين من المفاوضات بوساطه قطريه اتفاق
يقضي بافراج طهران عن خمسه سجناء امريكيين
مقابل اطلاق سراح خمسه من الايرانيين
المعتقلين في الولايات المتحده اضافه الى
تحرير واشنطن كل الاموال الايرانيه
المجمده في كوريا الجنوبيه وجزء منها في
العراق بمجموع يقدر بعشره مليارات دولار
طهران تتحدث عن حصولها على ضمانات امريكيه
بشان التزام واشنطن ببنود الصفقه مع هذا
لم تفرج عن السجناء الامريكيين ما لم
تتاكد من نقل اموالها الى قطر ما كاد مجلس
اداره نادي الوحدات الاردني ينتهي من
اعلانه عن موافقه اعضائه بالاجماع على
قرار اعتبر تطبيعا مع اسرائيل حتى استقال
سته اعضاء من المجلس رفضا للقرار فعن اي
اجماع تحدث البيان اللعب امام احد النوادي
الاماراتيه المطبعه مع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي احدث شرخا اداريا واغضب جمهور
النادي الذي وعد بانه اذا تمت المباراه
فسوف يقاطعها اعلنت الهيئه الاداريه لنادي
الوحدات عن قرارها بمشاركه الفريق الاول
لكره القدم في الملحق التمهيدي لمسابقه
دوري ابطال اسيا امام شباب الاهلي
الاماراتي والذي يضم بصفوفه اللاعب
الفلسطيني مؤنس دبور والذي سبق له ان مثل
منتخب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما ان النادي
الاماراتي خاض مباراه وديه مع احد انديه
الاحتلال قرار لم ينهي القضيه الشائكه
اطلاقا فقد اعقبته موجه من الاستقالات
لاعضاء مجلس الاداره جماهير الوحدات
اشتعلت غضبا
مطالباتهم في كل مكان وعلى مواقع التواصل
بعدم خوض المباراه والا فالمدرج الذي
لطالما امتلا بالجماهير سيغدو فارغا مؤنس
دبور لاعب فلسطيني اخذ الاحتلال قدمه
فاسقط راسه في افلام التطبيع وروايات
العسل المغشوش مؤنس دبور من مواليد
الناصره لاعب منتخب كيان الاحتلال وصفته
الصحف العبريه في تموز يوليو الماضي بانه
افضل لاعبا في تاريخ اسرائيل لم تقف مهمته
عند كونه لاعبا يمثل اسرائيل بل وظف
الاحتلال صورته لبث مقاله عنه انه رسائل
سلام وتعايش وديمقراطيه حمله دعائيه
لتلميع صفحات اسرائيل وحجب جرائمها بحق
الفلسطينيين والمقدسات فكانت منصاتها
تشارك صوره وفيديوهاته وهو يؤدي صلاه
الجمعه وفي جهه اخرى كانت تعتدي على المص
في المسجد الاقصى انتحارات بالجمله وبطرق
متعدده بينها الحرق اعتمدها جلود
اسرائيليون بعد خدمتهم في جيش الاحتلال
على الحدود مع قطاع غزه
حكاياتهم رواها زملائهم في الخدمه امام
جلسه برلمانيه للكنيسه مبلله بالدموع دموع
الخوف والكابه
تخيلوا ان هذا الجيش ما يزال يحتل فلسطين
منذ 75 عاما
[موسيقى]
تموتين
لاما لاما
للتخلص من اعراض الكابه ومن الكراهيه
والحروب لابد من الرقص نصيحه من موقع
اسرائيل بالعربيه الذي اعاد دون مناسبه
نشر فيديو عمره اكثر من سنه لما بدا انه
حفله دينيه يهوديه شارك فيها اماراتيون
دون ان يحدد زمانها ومكانها وكتب الموقع
الرقص والموسيقى لغه عالميه تساهم في
تاليف القلوب ودوله الامارات هي دوله
التفاهم والتسامح والتقارب
[موسيقى]
قتل جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شابين
فلسطينيين احدهما قاصر خلال مداهمه في
مخيم عقبه جبر بالضفه الغربيه المحتله
النائب التركي المعارض جمال انجينورت
يعترض على تحيه السلام عليكم بعد ان وجه
الرئيس اداره الشؤون الدينيه قبل شهور
باشاعه سلام المسلمين بين الناس بدل صباح
الخير باللغه التركيه
اذا كان جمال صادقا في عنصريته المقيته
عليه ان يغير فورا اسمه العربي ليس فقط
لعدم تطابقه مع المسمى ايضا في اخبار جنود
عنصريه المعارضه التركيه ولمجرد قول
الداعيه الشيخ خليل كونكشي ان مدينه هاتاي
يعيش فيها الكثير من العرب والاكراد حرفوا
كلامه وطالبوا باعدامه خارج القانون يعني
اسلام
محمد مصطفى
اذا لا يعتبر الشيخ خليل كونكتشي ان
القضيه قوميه بل هي صراع مع الاسلام
ومستقبله في تركيا فكيف قرا هؤلاء خبر
مشاركه نحو مليونين ونصف مليون طالب في
دورات القران الكريم الصيفيه على امتداد
تركيا احده هؤلاء التلاميذ طفل صغير بكى
امام امه بحرقه شديده عندما علم من دروس
السيره النبويه الشريفه لاول مره بوفاه
الرسول محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام
[موسيقى]
ختاما من الادب الروسي الساخر سال حفيد
جده لماذا اعتقلتك الحكومه ثلاث مرات يا
جدي فاجابه كنت شابا حين كنت مرافقا لمفوض
الحزب الشيوعي في موسكو وعندما وصلنا الى
مبنى الرئاسه الكرمبلين قال لي هل تعلم
اننا جعلنا صوره الكرملين عاليا كي لا
يقفز الحمير من فوقه قلت له سيقفزون من
الخارج للداخل ام من الداخل للخارج
فاعتقلوني ولم يفرجوا عني الا بعد ان مات
زعيم الحزبستالي فرحت بالحريه ووضعت صوره
الزعيم الخلف خروتشوب بجانب صوره ستالين
علم مفوض الحزب الذي كان يكره ستالين
فاستدعاني وسالني هل لا زلت تضع صوره هذا
الحمار سالته اي منهما سيدي فاع الى السجن
ولم يفرجوا عني حتى عزل خروتشوف في المره
الاخيره كنت احتفل بعيد ميلاد احد احفادي
اتصل بي مفوض الحزب وقال لي لماذا لم تاتي
الى اجتماع الحزب الاخير فاجبته لو علمت
انه الاخير لجئت مع كل عائلتي واحتفلنا
فاعتقلوني للمره الثالثه والاخيره
والخلاصه اذا كان الاستبداد يضيق صدره
بالسخريه اللطيفه فماذا يفعل اذا
بالمعارضين الجادين الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]